our ability to travel faster across the
world has consistently been a catalyst
for change this effect can be seen right
back to the domestication of the horse
it allows civilizations to expand and
spread information and resources faster
than ever so where is the next great
innovation and commercial travel fastest
civilian vehicle Concorde had a top
speed of Mach 2 but it needed to fly at
18,000 meters if it flew lower the
dragon heat generated from aerodynamic
friction would limited its top speed
consider this the outside temperature at
this altitude is minus 57 degrees
Celsius yet the nose of the Concorde
could reach 127 degrees naturally if we
want to move faster closer to the
Earth's surface we need a way to limit
the friction our vehicles experience
this is exactly what the Hyperloop aims
to do so how does it work the pressure
inside the Hyperloop tube will be lower
to a fraction of the normal atmospheric
pressure this minimizes the friction the
vehicle will experience due to air but
even having a small amount of air in the
tube can cause some serious issues due
to something called a Kantrowitz limit
at lower speeds there is enough space
between the pod and the tube for air to
get by but as the speed increases this
reaches a limit and the pod begins to
push large volumes of air ahead of it
this limits the speed immensely we can
fix this by installing a compressor fan
on the front of the pod that removes the
air from the front and redirects it to
the back for additional thrust or it can
be used to levitate the pod on a cushion
of air to help make this idea a reality
a competition sponsored by SpaceX was
created one team called our loop formed
on reddit and has recently started their
crowdfunding campaign to build their
prototype the prototype model has a
target speed of 480 km/h at this speed
there is no counter it's choking so
their design does not need a compressor
fan most teams have opted to forego the
compressor fan as a short test track
prohibits high speed runs our loop have
also moved away from Elon Musk's the
original idea of levitating the pod
using an air cushion their calculations
showed that it would be difficult to
achieve adequate lift with this method
they have instead opted to use 8x packs
levitation engines they will be
competing against 29 other teams most of
whom are backed by university funding
they rely on the support of communities
like reddit if you'd like to support
their project I provided a link in the
description with your assistance their
work may help usher in a new era of
transportation